[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au soir tous les petits enfants bruce
soord j'espère que vous avez été très
sage aujourd'hui il faut être sage car
le père noël va bientôt arriver
je le bien moi l'opr vol ce soir nicolas
et pimprenelle sont très occupés ils
décorent leurs beaux sapins de bord et
j'ai bien l'impression que beaucoup de
petits enfants préparent un beau sapin
de noël
je descends les yeux du patron les
arbres de noël c'est ma spécialité je me
connais d'accord mangue rené hauss asie
vite et hop boulot seul au poteau
le talent c'est tout jeune veut pas
tenir bien faire nicolas t'as raison pas
première
aux ennemis mais c'est pas des boucles
d'oreilles de mouassa ou lit mais sur le
sapin regarde bien comme ça là où il l'a
et puis encore in il a fait attention
aux enfants
tu vas aller casser accroche les à
l'ordre là c'est bien qu'ils sont
terribles échéances
quant à l'enfant bonsoir les petits ont
le là que c'est pau vous avez bien
travaillé mes petits neveux chez oui
ils sont sages qu'il travaille bien aux
totaux tu as deux profils d'argent tu
vois il faut les mettre sur l'arbre
comme ça vous connaissez l'histoire de
ses fils d'argent non
la voilà
des coûts des biens
il y avait
il ya bien longtemps tout près de la
forêt un joli coquelicot ou moins
concluants ce coquelicots avait une
grande amie qui s'appelait mademoiselle
a régné dans la voix panos elle est
cachée dans les branches et le soir de
noël
ce pauvre petit coquelicots et être
triste car il te tout seul et la
gentille araignées pour lui faire
plaisir avec l'aide de trois petits
lutins blond un tapis c est recouvert
tous les sapins de la forêt de file de
fils d'argent magnifique qu'on a appelés
des cheveux dans
oh oh que c'est magnifique non mais
votre sympa et du corps eut éliminé 9
est maintenant dispo chez rémi toto et
fanfan aller au dodo en vitesse je me
sauve les petits sinon je vais me faire
grand du bois de nuit un taux bas les
neuf alors les marmots olé olé moi c'est
la fin de la journée
elle au moment de ce congé nous raison
comme nos amis ils seront tous au lit
non c'est long aussi sur son nuage
certain moment le match à blaton il nous
dira permis boussieux et dormait tous
les deux nous sommes bien dans notre lit
nono son choix elle aubenas nuit jargon
je vois
on peut réfléchir
[Musique]
comme il est je vais m'endormir
ça envoie nous fait plaisir
[Musique]
bonne nuit toute la petite maisonnée
bonne nuit des enfants à 2 voilà
nounours revoir leur patron elle était
très jolie ton histoire
j'espère qu'elle vous a plu les enfants
bien sûr que l'or a plu n'est ce pas que
le toefl mon histoire lezons fonds
allant en route gros nounours vantard
bonne nuit les enfants à demain brooke
bundy
[Musique]
oh